Una semana, tan sólo una semana es el tiempo
que ha necesitado este hombre, el nuevo Presidente
de Estados Unidos, para tener su primera gran
crisis diplomática ¿Con quién? Por supuesto,
lo sabéis, con México.
Donald Trump es… único, tal vez sólo él
sea capaz de retar públicamente a un presidente
extranjero, en este caso a Peña Nieto, diciéndole
por Twitter que si no va a Washington con
la idea de pagar el muro, mejor que se quede
en casa.
Por supuesto, la visita nunca se produjo.
Pero tranquilos, porque Donald no va a ser
el protagonista, al menos principal, de este
vídeo.
Hace un tiempo hicimos este vídeo sobre el
TPP y lo errada que podía ser la política
proteccionista de Trump. Entonces muchos de
vosotros nos pedisteis que hablásemos del
NAFTA, del tratado de libre comercio de Norteamérica.
Y eso es, precisamente, lo que vamos a hacer
hoy en este vídeo, prestando especial atención
a la relación México – EEUU.
EL NAFTA
El NAFTA en inglés, o TLCAN es castellano,
es un acuerdo de libre comercio entre Estados
Unidos, Canadá y México. Fue negociado y
firmado por el Presidente George Bush padre
en 1992, y ratificado e implantado por Bill
Clinton en el 94.
Es decir, el Nafta ha sido apoyado en Estados
Unidos tanto por Demócratas como por Republicanos.
Pero, haciendo un poco de historia, prestemos
atención a cuáles han sido los acontecimientos
en el lado sur del rio bravo.
Viajemos hasta mediados de la década de los
80, en aquel momento México estaba agotado,
su modelo era el de una economía cerrada
y la verdad, ya no daba más de sí, la situación
de crisis era casi continua.
De hecho, en ese momento comenzó realmente
la emigración masiva a EEUU, ojo, no hablamos
de cualquier cosa sino de una de las mayores
olas migratorias de todos los tiempos.
Y eso a pesar de que por aquel entonces los
gringos no caían precisamente bien en México.
Desde que, en la guerra con Estados Unidos,
entre 1846 y 1848, México perdiese más de
la mitad de su territorio, el sentimiento
popular en este país veía a EEUU como el
gran villano, el gran enemigo.
Pero el caso es que en 1988 cuando estaba
claro que el modelo había fracasado, el entonces
Presidente de México, Carlos Salinas, que
se había formado por cierto en Harvard, decidió
dar carpetazo al modelo y apostar por abrirse
al mundo. En sus propias palabras:
“Estados Unidos no es la mayor amenaza,
sino la mayor oportunidad”
Y desde luego, los líderes norteamericanos
no perdieron la ocasión, se pusieron manos
a la obra y decidieron apostar por extender
a México el Acuerdo de Libre Comercio que
recientemente habían firmado con Canadá.
Así surgió el TLCAN, el NAFTA.
Desde entonces las relaciones entre Estados
Unidos se han multiplicado casi exponencialmente.
Hoy las relaciones comerciales entre ambos
países superan ampliamente los 500.000 millones
de dólares,
Para que os hagáis una idea, por cada minuto
que pasa, más de 1 millón de dólares en
productos atraviesa la frontera entre Estados
Unidos y México.
Es decir, solo el tráfico comercial entre
EEUU y México equivale a dos veces toda la
economía de Chile y es mayor que la economía
de Argentina.
Pues bien, el actual inquilino de la Casa
Blanca, Donald Trump amenaza, incluso, con
tumbar este tratado, porque según dice es
el peor acuerdo para los intereses de Estados
Unidos jamás firmado.
Eso es lo que él dice, la realidad es un
poco diferente. El NAFTA ha sido, en general,
una mina de oro para los Estados Unidos.
IMPLICACIONES DEL NAFTA Y MÉXICO PARA ESTADOS
UNIDOS
Dicen por ahí que cuando Trump tiene una
pesadillas ve a un mexicano robándole la
cartera.
En fin, no se si será verdad, pero esta historia
explicaría porque Donald tiene tanta obsesión
con Mexico y también porque cada vez que
escucha la palabra Nafta su cerebro grita:
Robo, robo.
Pero, ojo, no os penseis que es el único
que piensa así. así.
Muchos defensores del proteccionismo en Estados
Unidos afirman que los trabajadores mexicanos
y canadienses le hacen perder cada año a
su país miles de millones de dólares por
culpa del libre comercio.
En concreto, dicen que las importaciones superan
cada año a las exportaciones en casi 80.000
millones, que se dice pronto.
El problema, es que esta cifra tiene más
agujeros que un queso gruyer.
En primer lugar, hay dos productos que distorsionan
todos los datos y que no tienen nada que ver
con el Nafta: ¡el petróleo y el gas natural!!!
Ojo, porque si excluimos estos productos ese
agujero comercial que denuncia Trump desaparece
casi por completo.
Vale, tal vez alguno de vosotros esté pensando
en este momento: pero Enrique ¿por qué no
quieres tener en cuenta el petróleo y el
gas natural? Pues porque salvo que Trump quiera
devolver a Estados Unidos a la edad de piedra,
digo yo que tendrá que seguir comprando todo
el petróleo que necesita, ya sea de Canadá,
México, Arabia Saudí o la conchinchina.
Y aún no termina el juego de magia de estos
ilusionistas del proteccionismo. Aun queda
otra trampa : el dato de déficit comercial
que presentan casi nunca tiene en cuenta los
servicios, es decir el sector financiero,
los seguros, los viajes, las consultoras,
¡internet!, etc
Claro, ya sabemos todos que los bancos no
ganan dinero y que Google no existe ¿Verdad?
Pues bien, si corregimos estas dos trampas,
resulta que EEUU no solo no tiene déficit
sino que obtiene un superávit en sus relaciones
con Canadá y México de más de 40.000 millones
de dólares. Vamos que en todo caso los bandoleros
serían los gringos.
Pero vale, es verdad, el caso de México es
un poco diferente porque aun corrigiendo las
trampas EEUU sigue teniendo déficit, asi
que la pregunta que podemos hacernos es ¿de
cuanto?
Pues, agarraos a la silla, de aproximadamente…
el 0,25% del PIB
Sí, lo sé, no es mucho, siento defraudarte.
De hecho, es un déficit menor que el que
EEUU mantiene, por supuesto con China, pero
también con Japón o Alemania, por ejemplo.
Y aquí no acaba la historia.
LA INDUSTRIA AUTOMOTRIZ
Casi todas las industrias de EEUU exportan
más a México de lo que importan salvo la
de los automóviles.
Pero claro, es que las compañías que más
coches “hechos en México” venden a los
Estados Unidos, son precisamente las de origen
estadounidenses, como Ford o General Motors.
Así que ya sabéis donde van a parar los
beneficios generados ¿Verdad? Sí, así es,
regresan a Estados Unidos, tanto en forma
de coches más baratos como de beneficios
listos para ser distribuidos entre sus millones
de accionistas.
Pero aún hay más… se suele decir que la
razón principal para que las empresas lleven
sus fábricas a México son los salarios,
bueno esto es una verdad a medias, la razón
principal no es esa. NO.
Lo que más le interesa a las compañías
de coches es que a día de hoy México tiene
muchos más tratados de libre comercio que
Estados Unidos lo que les permite producir
en este país y vender en mercados como Brasil
o la Unión Europea horrándose un montón
de aranceles. Más de 700 millones de dólares
cada año.
“BRASIL AMA LOS AUTOS HECHOS EN MÉXICO”
Y ¿Dónde va a parar el beneficio de estas
operaciones? Lo habéis adivinado, a Estados
Unidos.
Cómo en los casinos, la casa siempre gana.
Es decir, gracias a México las compañías
automovilísticas de Estados Unidos son más
competitivas y tienen más beneficios al tiempo
que, insisto, los CONSUMIDORES de Estados
Unidos PUEDEN COMPRAR SUS COCHES MUCHO MÁS
BARATOS.
Llegados a este punto una buena pregunta sería
¿Qué hacen los Yankis contantos beneficios?
Pues cómo decía Bastiat, van a parar a lo
que no se ve: con más dinero en el bolsillo
los ciudados de estados unidos compran más
ropa, van más al cine, cambian más de Smartphone´s
y suma y sigue, la ruleta continúa girando.
Tal vez por ello, las cifras de empleo en
Estados Unidos estén en récord histórico.
De hecho, según las investigaciones realizadas,
acabar con esta relación le supondría a
Estados Unidos perder más de 5 millones de
puestos de trabajo.
IMPLICACIONES DEL NAFTA Y EEUU PARA MÉXICO
Sí México es importante para Estados Unidos,
la inversa es enorme. Casi el 80% de las exportaciones
mexicanas van a su vecino del norte.
Así que no es extraño, que la amenaza de
Trump haya hecho recordar esa célebre frase
que se dice pronunció Porfirio Díaz:
“Pobre México, tan lejos de Dios y tan
cerca de EEUU”
El TLCAN ha sido muy, muy positivo para México.
Por ejemplo, ¿Sabéis quien es hoy el mayor
empleador de este país? Pues es, Walt Mart.
Sin embargo, desgraciadamente, este fenómeno
no se ha visto en el crecimiento de México,
que es cuando menos anémico ¿Por qué? Pues
aquí amigo toca buscar responsabilidades
dentro del país.
Lo cierto es que los políticos mexicanos
no han sabido aprovechar esta fantástica
oportunidad para modernizar el país y hacerlo
competitivo. Y eso que gracias a los altísimos
precios del petróleo han tenido recursos
de sobra para hacerlo. Pero ya sabéis, malas
políticas malos resultados.
Ahora bien, ¿quiere decir esto que México
se tiene que arrodillar ante Donald Trump?
Ni mucho menos.
¿CÓMO SE PUEDE DEFENDER MÉXICO?
Donald Trump ha amenazado a México con imponer
fuertes aranceles a sus productos SI SE NIEGAN
A PAGAR SU MURO, en concreto su administración
ha hablado de un 20%.
Esto de entrada sería ilegal, porque hay
una norma de la Organización Mundial del
Comercio que lo prohíbe, en concreto la conocida
como regla de la Nación Más Favorecida,
que viene a decir que ningún país miembro
de la OMC puede discriminar a ningún otro.
De facto, esto limitaría el arancel máximo,
en caso de tumbarse el NAFTA al 3%, lo que
sería un impuesto a los consumidores y empresas
estadounidenses que prácticamente no afectaría
al tráfico comercial entre Estados Unidos
y México.
Pero incluso si EEUU, con la aprobación del
Congreso, estaría dispuesto a saltarse la
legalidad internacional, México tiene herramientas
para combatir y tratar de impedirlo:
Primero tiene que poner de su lado toda la
influencia de las grandes multinacionales
que podrían miles de millones de pérdidas.
Y ojo, no hablamos de tres o cuatro empresarios
sino por ejemplo de todos los trabajadores
de estas empresas y de sus accionistas, millones
de ahorradores de los Estados Unidos.
Y en segundo lugar, las relaciones entre EEUU
y México no son solo comerciales: inmigración,
narcotráfico, terrorismo… Sí Trump ataca,
México podría contraatacar por ejemplo,
lavándose las manos e inundando EEUU de droga
y oleadas de inmigrantes de diferentes países
de Latinoamérica.
Estados Unidos y México se necesitan mucho
más de lo que parece, y desde luego México
no está en una posición tan débil como
Trump se cree. Parece que Peña Nieto esto
si lo ha entendido y desde el gobierno de
México se dice: muy bien, hablemos el Nafta,
renegociemos el tratado, pero también otros
acuerdos.
Bueno, ¿tú que crees? ¿Debe México defenderse
con uñas y dientes incluso a riesgo de desencadenar
una guerra comercial con su vecino del norte?
¿O acaso debe ser paciente, dar largas y
buscan una conciliación? Esperamos vuestras
respuestas, nos las podéis dejar en los comentarios
y así poder abrir debate.
Por supuesto si os ha resultado interesante
este vídeo no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros
al canal, a este y también a nuestra versión
en inglés, que la verdad, creo que está
quedando de cine. Y por si fuese poco, también
nos puedes ver todos los domingos en la Vanguardia.
Por cierto, si quieres conocer más sobre
las políticas económicas de Trump y en particular
que gran error está cometiendo en el Pacífico,
no te pierdas este vídeo.
¡Un saludo y hasta la próxima amigos!